so that is the influential the roof of
the school building blew off during a
storm last year for now lessons are
taking place here where church services
are usually held the students don't know
when or if they'll have a proper
classroom again we are pleading that's
when the city is our problems they
should come to our eat to help us solve
it because we are all ghanaians and we
all need to be treated equally
state-run schools in Ghana have been
struggling for years now the government
is having to cut public spending to meet
conditions imposed by the international
monetary fund as part of a three billion
dollar loan
some here worry that could mean even
less money for the already underfunded
education sector
despite government efforts to improve
the quality of Education in public
schools challenges remain many schools
like this one don't have enough
resources such as textbooks properly
trained teachers and desks what is one
government leaders say there will be no
major budget cuts to health or education
but some people don't believe this in
June thousands failed exams to qualify
as teachers because of the IMF
conditionality which is putting a cup on
the number of persons that can be
employed by government to become part of
government expenditure
government has found a way of denying
the almost
7 000 teachers the qualification to
become teachers so that government
doesn't feel compelled
to employ them
for people to know what effect the IMF
loan will have on their country those
desperate for conditions to improve can
only wait in hope for the best